let's talk to why don't we go to the 7 1
3 area code who's calling today from 7 1
3 hi David this is Gabe I'm from Houston
Texas hey Gabe what's going on so I saw
that poll that came out I'm sure you saw
it too regarding AOC and Omar how their
polling at I think it's 22 percents of
AOC and maybe 9% for L on Omar well
here's the thing there's two polls that
came out one of them is only polling
like white people with under two years
of college education or something like
that that one is not surprisingly
drastically understating the overall
support for those members of Congress
there's another poll which the numbers
still aren't amazing but they're way
better than the ones Trump cited so
which of the two polls were you talking
about I think I was talking about the
former poll but we on that has the lower
results because I've been hearing a lot
of talk from conservatives that this
will be used to kind of sideline or
force aoc and the squad to be silent in
their opposition to the establishment
because they could potentially be
harmful to the Democratic nominee do you
see that as a potential kind of strategy
used by conservatives or should should
these poll numbers be kind taken with a
grain of salt listen you don't
understand us any poll the country is
more than white people with under two
years of college so first of all any
poll that tells you someone is popular
or unpopular merely by polling white
people under two with under two years of
college education is not an accurate
poll so that would be a really stupid
poll to use to justify those four
members of Congress being a risk to the
Democratic Party what most importantly
we have to think about is they don't
have to even win over Democrats in the
entire country in order to keep getting
reelected all that matters is their
district a lot of those districts so
certainly with a o'seas district and
maybe also with Elon Omar's district
those are blue districts and so the real
challenge to those members of Congress
is more likely to come from within the
Democratic Party rather than from a
Republican and if you
I believe it's a YouGov poll they still
don't have the best favorability ratings
but they are slightly better than the
Democratic Party in total which means
they're probably on track for
re-election in their in their respective
districts so I just don't see the math
justifying this concern that the right
says Democrats should have about the
four of them they seem to be popular
enough to get reelected in their own
districts yeah that's what I was
thinking of course because obviously you
look at people like Mitchell is one of
the most senators out there but it's not
like he's going to be potentially
harmful to the Republican Party and he
has no trouble about getting reelected
well maybe he will in 2020 I know
there's some opposition but yeah
obviously if you just take those numbers
over to the Republicans the math Justin
yeah justify that yeah and I think the
important thing to understand is even
though Mitch McConnell's favorability in
his state is not that high it doesn't
mean that Republican voters in Kentucky
are going to vote for a Democrat they
might prefer a different Republican but
in the end they'll still vote for Mitch
McConnell and the opposite is true in a
lot of these Democratic districts as
well so I think that it's it's really
kind of a very empty attack at least at
this point in time okay well glad for
glad to hear from you on that it's been
uh ever since that okay and I think why
me and my liberal friends have been kind
of worried about this so so glad to hear
a an objective take on those poll
numbers appreciate it thank you great to
hear from you appreciate the call